hello welcome to the video series of bio
techniques explained in five minutes
where I explain simple concepts of
biology and the techniques in a time
less than five minutes or so so if you
haven't yet subscribed to my channel hit
the subscribe button and let's start
today's technique is about methods to
study DNA protein interaction it is
important because many of the cases
let's say you have identified a protein
and you think that protein interacts
with DNA possibly that protein is a
transcription factor so how do you prove
it or how do you do experiments to prove
your hypothesis that that protein
interacts with the DNA a simplest method
is electro phoretic mobility shift assay
we all know if we load DNA on a gel it
would move and based on its size so
let's say we have our sample where we so
we have only DNA we have only purified
DNA and we run it and that has a
characteristic band now let's say our
protein of interest is interacting with
the DNA so definitely if it is
interacting the DNA the mobility on the
gel would be less so that shift in
mobility could be understood that the
understood as a readout of that the
protein is interacting with the target
DNA so this is one of the easiest way by
which can we buy we which we can
understand DNA protein interaction other
thing is DNA's fruit printing assay it
turns out like when we walk on the sand
on the seashore so we leave our
footprint similarly when RNA polymerase
or any DNA binding protein is binding to
the DNA it is leaving a footprint there
and what is the footprint and how it is
read so let's say this is the DNA and
you chop the DNA in fragments and then
you do a autoradiogram and let's say the
DNA is bound to a protein which is
possibly a transcription factor or DNA
interacting protein then you would get
different size of fragments but you
don't get some amount of fragments
because
that region is protected by the binding
of the DNA that's why DNA's one cannot
leave those regions and those size
fragment characteristic fragments are
absent then we can backtrack and tell
that the protein is interacting with the
DNA at that particular region and it has
left a footprint but all these methods
are pretty qualitative so one
quantitative method is chromatin
immunoprecipitation followed by
sequencing which would tell us that what
exact sequence is our protein of
interest is binding so in order to do do
that so this method use DNA protein
interaction study and it can be used in
in vitro or in vivo it used antibody
coated beads and let's say we know that
this particular protein we have an
antibody against this particular protein
so we would use the antibody to pull
down the protein and we would see what
DNA region is pulled down along with
that particular protein so let's say
there are a multiple type of this
particular protein of interest could
interact with one part of the genome or
maybe it can interact with multiple
different part of the genome so once we
pull it down using an antibody coated
bead then whatever region it interacts
with all comes down in a pulldown
fraction and from the pulldown fraction
we can isolate the DNA and after that
what we can do is we can run a
sequencing experiment that would tell us
that what sequence are associated with
that
so the sequencing machine readout would
tell us which specific sequence are
enriched in that pulldown fraction so
what came along with that pulled down
protein of interest what sequences came
out and the enrichment Peaks would tell
us what sequences that DNA probably bind
to if we don't have huge amount of
funding for to a sequencing because
sequencing experiments are costly then
one can also do pulldown and after that
taking the DNA out and performing qPCR
to understand
whether out of many genes our protein
bind to one of our gene of interest or
not so it's a candidate approach that
means our protein is possibly can bind
to many of the targets but at this
moment I wanted to know that this
particular protein of interest whether
it is binding to my gene of interest
that I am studying at so that could be
used using chip qPCR so these are all
the techniques possible techniques by
which DNA protein interaction could be
measured I hope this video was
informative if you like my video give it
a quick thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you